[Music]
an all-female dance group from lebanon
leaves the judges mesmerized on
america's got talent i had been very
impressed already this season yeah it's
been you know
such an amazing
uh
amount of talented people sofia vergara
can't look away from this striking dance
number and neither can we
we're gonna try to hypnotize you
okay so we are ready to get hypnotized
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the group is called the mayas the
meaning behind their name the proud walk
of a lioness and they had plenty of
reasons to be proud as they entered the
competition amid season 17 auditions the
group's choreographer nadim says they
were inspired to give it a shot after
watching former contestant nightbird the
singer who was forced to exit the show
to focus on her cancer battle back in
2021
where she said
[Music]
we can't wait until life isn't hard
anymore before you decide to be happy
[Music]
seeing the miles in america's got talent
is the most beautiful feeling i've ever
felt but it's the maya's own touching
story that has us and the judges in awe
what is your dream
us being here standing on the biggest
stage of the world is our only chance to
prove to the world what
arab woman can do
the art we can create the fights we
fight
by the end of the act we see why the
mayas are a total package
[Music]
[Applause]
the group received a standing ovation
from judges simon cowell heidi klum
howie mandel and sofia vergara and rave
reviews all around
it was the most beautiful creative
dancing i've ever seen we were
hypnotized by what you did
i want to thank you for giving us a
little glimpse of your culture which is
so beautiful it was
arguably
the best dance act
we're likely to have ever
and we are honored to have you here
but it's sophia's feedback that changes
their lives forever
[Music]
yep sophia slams the golden buzzer
sending the mayas straight to the live
represents shows arabs women lebanese
women can are capable to do
and like this is like a life-changing
experience et spoke to sophia back in
april and she teased that while the
stakes are higher than last season there
are also more rewards we have an extra
golden buzzer that we had last season
though
and that was that is amazing because
sometimes we feel that there's it's not
fair that we don't have more of them
because everyone is getting so good
[Music]
you